welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and as we look ahead to the loki
finale who the hell is in that castle at
the end of time who created the tva in
its timekeeper robots and are we
guaranteed to be ralph bonnard yet again
boner well i wanted to make my best
arguments for
and against all top eight suspects so
that hopefully we can all go into this
finale more open-minded for the
possibilities rather than clinging to
one expectation that some might base
their enjoyment of this whole show on
the validity of look folks kang and
mephisto might heat up a party but you
don't need them for an enjoyable night
of tabletop gaming i think i know what
that means
let's start with suspect number one kang
the conqueror aka immortus aka nathaniel
richards aka the pharaoh rama tut how
many of these are there aka mr gryffin
head of
king enterprises the company that
overtakes stark tower in the comics and
the latest loki easter egg pointing in
the direction of kang
now many skeptical viewers are comparing
kang to mephisto in one division just
another goofy big
bad from the comics that nerds are
making mountains out of easter egg
molehills to justify
i mean that could be the case but the
truth is there are far
more clues pointing to kang's arrival
than we ever had for mephisto with
mephisto
our evidence was cryptic mentions of
devils and demon spawns satanic imagery
and parallels to a comic storyline in
which mephisto was the villain behind it
all but by episode 7 of the show the
series revealed it was agatha all along
but with loki
very different situation headed into the
finale we do not have an agatha all
along yet
there's still some man behind the
curtain and unlike mevisto kang the
conqueror has been confirmed
and cast in the mcu and a spoiler
warning for black widow seriously if you
haven't seen it skip the next 10 seconds
or so marvel studios just proved it's
not afraid to introduce big names first
on disney plus shows
with mystery woman val appearing on the
falcon the winner soldier before her
cameo now in black widow
also of all the tva judges in the comics
they could have chosen the writers
picked ravona rinslayer
arguably best known as kang's romantic
interest similarly eliath the writers
could have made up a smoke monster or
picked any number of lesser beasts from
marvel lore
and they chose the one best known for
threatening kang's temporal
empire the void's possession of the
pyramids and the sphinx mirrors the
historical trophies kang keeps in his
chronopolis kingdom the central
timekeeper that the cinematography
keeps focusing on looks like an android
kang could have made in his own image
kang prime in the comics does reside at
the end of time where this citadel is
located
and loki is a time travel series kang is
marvel's ultimate time travel villain it
just
lines up now if the void is made up of
things that the tva
pruned and if kang were running the tva
why would they
prune things from a kang dominated
timeline well if the tva is
all kang's machinery the void's true
purpose
could be to collect things that kang
actually wants and eliath could be the
snake in his garden that kang
needed sylvie to slay or kang could be a
tva prisoner kept in solitary
confinement and eliath was keeping him
there
look it might not be kang but anyone who
says that it's definitely not kang
is either dismissing a very likely
possibility for just being too
obvious to them kind of like what mobius
said it's always the game within the
game with you guys
which i respect or people are just
afraid of looking wrong after mephisto
to which i say if you like this stuff
this much being right isn't going to
make you cool so just be the greater
fool and own it and that brings us to
suspect 2 king loki trailer footage
shots still yet to be shown on the
series show a smug
loki on the throne of asgard and another
shot shows loki back
in stark tower redoing the events of the
battle of new york
glorious we know the tva targets loki's
in particular
and since this show is about loki
variants it would make sense for the man
behind the curtain to be some alpha loki
who created the tva in order to erase
all other variant competitors to his
rule
and one who would represent the darkest
parts of loki's soul that our
protagonist has been battling internally
now you could also say this might
contradict the trajectory the series has
been
following right like each episode
introduces us to increasingly diverse
loki variants each with a different face
from a female to an old man to a kid to
a reptile so to pull back the final
curtain just to reveal
the face of tom hiddleston again i mean
i don't know
loki just did that in episode five
opening the hatch to
president loki and then shortly after
the show turned him into a kind of a
joke
so it might seem like a step backward to
reveal yet
another tom hiddleston loki but evil
this time
even though we spent two and a half
movies with that version of the
character already
folks these trailer shots could just be
visions of a hypothetical timeline in
which loki rules as king
illusions conjured by whoever is behind
the curtain to try to tempt loki now
just to cover our bases we could look at
suspect number three
mobius with his perceived
inconsistencies of not remembering
leaving ring stains not remembering an
alligator loki as a sign that there
could be some other mobius variant
or mobius could be a loki variant but it
does seem like owen wilson was
cast on this show to be a foil to loki
not to be some
maniacal crazy big bad he seems like
he's there to represent the awe shocks
in a sense of the tva workforce and of
course to ride a jet ski really for it
to matter that some characters are loki
variants
a lot of the other characters must not
be loki variants there's only so many
times you can play that card
similarly suspect number four rent
slayer already has a role to play in
uncovering this mystery so to reveal a
rinse layer variant behind the curtain
might muddy the current rinse layer arc
and set up a
weird rinse layer versus red slayer
conflict is that how we want the show to
end now if you like what we do here at
new rockstars one of the best ways you
can support that content and help us do
more is to grab some cool swag from
newrockstarsmerch.com our partners at
epic hero shop have put together a full
lineup of really cool gear
shirts hats hoodies water bottles all
kinds of stuff to make your friends your
family co-workers fellow arby's diners
jealous we also have our limited edition
black widow inspired latest obsession
shirt
i kind of play on the classic hourglass
logo super limited supply
we got another black widow shirt design
you might like as well as some loki
designs like the gator loki polo shirt
and the loki out of time tea that i'm
wearing the supply
is limited so you gotta act fast we've
already sold out of the xl and green and
a bunch of the red sizes but when you
buy a latest obsession shirt you
unlock the ability to leave a shout out
that will appear
on screen during our weekly inside
marvel episodes and you can finally tell
grandma how much you care
via a youtube video the epic hero shop
has a massive
all-original loki collection with other
shirt designs stickers even a miss
minutes wall clock check it out in
all of the other merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
you'll be helping our channel while also
earning major
nerd cred now there is suspect number
five casey not seen since episode two
and some are saying the name casey is a
clue k
c kang the conqueror i'm sorry i'm gonna
pass on that one
but suspect number six miss minutes is
worth considering
because we still don't know what she is
like she can transcend both digital
screens and
real space and she is close enough to
the heart of the tva to access
confidential records and
lie on behalf of it and tara strong
teased that there's so much more to be
revealed and that you don't really know
who she is where she's from what her
origin story is
how sentient she is miss minutes could
be the public face of whoever is
controlling the tva
and sylvie's vision glided up to that
lit tower and stopped at its golden glow
maybe connected to the color of miss
minutes and in this case the one
controlling the tva might be
no one and it's all part of some
self-perpetuating clockwork with
mechanized puppet authorities but what
threw me was the way these android
timekeepers
laughed when sylvie decapitated one of
them pretty weird response
i read that as some maniacal puppet
master who might have even wanted loki
and sylvia to make this discovery
that brings us to suspect number seven
dr doom whom some are connecting to the
european looking castle
the androids they say being similar to
doom bots and the possibility that
sorcery could have been used to enchant
the tba to block out the other forms of
magic but unlike kang
doom has not yet been cast or even
confirmed for the mcu he's coming
someday but probably not in the next few
years i think the people who are pushing
for doctor doom are just comic readers
who find king too confusing but in my
breakdown i brought up suspect number
eight
classic loki suggesting that he might
have faked his death with eliath similar
to the way he confessed to faking his
death with thanos i like this better
than king loki because it still checks
those boxes of loki basing an alpha
variant of himself
while letting richard e grant continue
to shine think about it classic loki is
insanely powerful he casts complex
duplicates
creating teleportation portals conjuring
a full asgard emerald city illusion
and in his final seconds as he was wiped
away by eliath he
let his green magic fade from his hands
and he was laughing and glee and noticed
how his cape
seemed to dematerialize before a life
got to him i'm definitely getting some
vibes of obi-wan surrendering to vader
to become more powerful
than you can possibly imagine and
classic loki had that interesting
response to mobius earlier
so just like that you're turning on the
very thing you diverted your life to
it's never too late to change it's just
hard to tell with him because grant is
so good an actor he released
that single tear as light and wind
pounded his face
which could have been him accepting his
fate or feeling a kind of excitement for
a different long-awaited release now you
may be asking why would classic loki
slum it in the void if he was really
running the tva from that castle beyond
well if we're really going by the man
behind the curtain logic
classic loki's theatrical costume could
be a duplicate
illusion that the real old man was
conjuring from that castle beyond maybe
the only thing that can subdue eliath is
enchantment the one form of sorcery that
he does not appear to have
because unlike loki l1130 and sylvie he
never had a connection with another he
lived his whole life alone on a remote
planet
that could be why he wanted sylvie and
loki to come here why the timekeepers
laughed
why loki's have been targeted i think
whoever is the man behind the curtain
one safe bet is that they will refer to
themselves as
he who remains that's the title of the
elderly tva agent at the end of time who
engineers the timekeepers and i say that
because really any of these suspects
could be he who remains
or he who remains might just be a
completely new face or even just
a note left by a guy named he who
remains on a miss minute's wall clock
connected to a bunch of cogs and levers
reading
out to lunch see you in a minute and
based on all of the evidence folks it's
just hard not to imagine that whoever it
is
if it's not kang it must have been
someone who created the tva at the
behest of or in response to
kang like even if gang is reduced to a
post-credit cameo or no sighting at all
his fingerprints are all over the series
and we're not talking devils in the
details
these are intentional clues so if you
are still in a kang gang after all this
i will be there with you because
mephisto's getting lonely in my daily
mentions
so where am i at i guess i'll say
classic loki he remains in a rivalry
against kang with miss minutes as his
automated assistant but i'm not putting
the house on that follow me on instagram
and twitter at eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
this is my final loki theory video
before the finale so i will see all of
you on the other side thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you